oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ] looks like Grandpa's
basement you tuned in on a good night
[ __ ] we're going deep in the
murky waters of the underworld tell your
grandmother go to bed you're taking my
painkillers go to bed though maybe you
ain't gonna waste my time watching
jeopardy go to bed we got it we got it
[ __ ]
you better strap on your seat belts of
young 18
get the [ __ ] off periscope you don't
belong there [ __ ] on your go do your
homework in your clunker go masturbate
in the bathroom like a normal 15 year
old watching your uncle Joey is smoking
dope and what they don't even why they
watch
they say is [ __ ] oh [ __ ] is going on
there with the [ __ ] things going on
in this is Jewish lightning [ __ ]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] no it's always a good day we
must do the acid that takes cause a game
of stars for one I made the [ __ ] 14
1500
do that some thing that's why I don't do
that's why I don't have a dab ring I
don't need they know I don't goddamn I
don't dabble
I don't need new [ __ ] toys yeah yeah
that shit's cranky yeah it's - I got a
bigger bullpup phone just [ __ ] go get
[ __ ] Johnnie arabia and get a gram of
[ __ ] heroin once you bring a
blowtorch home yeah yeah yeah
it's never good okay not everybody was
having fun some Richard Pryor's on fire
yeah I smoke too [ __ ] and reflow some
people watch your mouth and blood boy
just not really not tonight [ __ ]
tonight's a different type of that Chris
Porter's here a [ __ ] lethal comedian
you understand it you guys are gonna
meet another savage of debt dan dan we
got ferries wet boots
we got liquid acid we got edibles up not
for me I'm on left with Lee's going
deeper than last night how many
[Music]
you bad [ __ ] you thought your
uncle Joey forgot about you not in a
million [ __ ] years you understand me
with doing bong hits for Jerry's kids
tonight this is the weed Jerry gives the
kids before you shoot some [ __ ]
enough you ain't making no money on the
[ __ ] that [ __ ] song ain't working no
more last time you can sang the song
without 1100 this time we got $11 it's
over Chris Paul is in the house his
beautiful girlfriend Lisa at when I
[ __ ] around for that it's a Monday
night if you're watching dancing that
was like the twilight zone his [ __ ]
something happen to moved up my camera's
all [ __ ] up now but who gives a [ __ ]
look back do I really
yeah do what the [ __ ] is going on in
there we go well Joey's back with the
[ __ ] job and the clap you saying here
we go
[Music]
oh and we got this [ __ ] look at this
tonight we're going beep this is the
[ __ ] that leaves you ready blue cookies
from perennial that's the [ __ ] look at
these buds I'm gonna show you and don't
show nobody else I'm just showing them
to you because I like you [ __ ]
take a look at this [ __ ]
BAM look at this boom BAM oh this is the
meteor that's gonna hit you all these
people media's gonna hit us in 2026 yeah
this is gonna hit you right in the
[ __ ] head you never you're never
gonna forget you uncle Joey
what else we got tonight I'm getting
ready for [ __ ] Baltimore I got the
snow but shovels I got my own [ __ ]
helicopter it's over then we got
perennial ba ba ba ba ba ba boom oh [ __ ]
nice look at this scrolling Colorado
drought look at this [ __ ] look at the
back of this look at that look at that
right there you're not getting this [ __ ]
where you live [ __ ] pick it play
take a chance Columbus dick that's all
I've ever asked you people stop [ __ ]
around move out to California get a
medical marijuana license get hit and
run and then you [ __ ] go back to your
neighborhood there's more hit and runs
in [ __ ] that way every day I watch
World News Tonight and [ __ ]
somebody's getting hit before another
bar LaRoche
we're playing games listen if you want
to play games get the [ __ ] out of here
oh hang out with your friends and go to
Starbucks and look at the little poker
that look at that
it's like finger banging somebody when
you're 15 look at that little finger
coming in there yeah yeah say something
what you want to eat then you eat
chicken I had it tonight remember
chicken piccata nice with some [ __ ]
green things I don't know what they
called my wife went on Kapus [ __ ]
delicious delicious
the veal Vava voom that's what getting
[ __ ] are [ __ ] awesome don't
worry about nothing uncle joy didn't
forget about you if you got a bong fill
it up listen we just took a shortcut
tonight the death we played we sold our
soul for rock and roll we just took a
shortcut to death and if you doing THC
always hydrate you understand me it
sucks out everything out of your [ __ ]
bones I gotta wake up in the middle of
night drink three gallons of [ __ ]
water I'm pissing all night so I drink
the water now so when I get home
everything comes out and I can sleep
like a [ __ ] Zombo I don't like people
bother me you ever wake up in the middle
I you got a PLA [ __ ] I'm going back to
bed I'll take my chances no that [ __ ]
you sleep up and throws and you have
metaphysical I like to get up like a
4-peat like if I look like tonight I'll
go to bed like 11:30 yeah well I wake up
like a 4:30 just to be and I go let's
take a look and see what's going on in
the world do you really a better job put
you to bed oh [ __ ] listen I bought a
benadryl an alpha brand in case of beer
you're going places [ __ ] you leave
any roller skates oh [ __ ] this is Lee
song in fact let's get the stars ready
oh [ __ ] come in my little girl
he just might as well eat the whole bag
what's this
he's like dice whatever come forth
hey what is that don't even count
he's a training facility all he could do
a lot of things trust me he'll be proud
because he's a training and [ __ ] cuz he
[ __ ] up all weekend look at Lee get
muscles on his arms look at him he's
getting bilking the [ __ ] he's going
through changes this is Lee's favorite
song he's going through changes this is
what happens you're not only in edibles
I get high on the reef when we take it
back to [ __ ] the eighth grade we're
happy go get a callaghan's hot dog [ __ ]
like that
everything is beautiful should we drink
a little cocktail again tonight if I
drink two nights in a row does that make
me an alcoholic what the [ __ ] is the
question here at hand
call me back 1 888 lick my nuts and let
me know if I drink beers two nights in a
row
does that make you an alcoholic and what
you think not that you let me see you
count some wolf [ __ ] count them
off that's right that's a good way of
looking at it
you're only an alcoholic if you got a
meeting less that's pretty philosophical
that's Confucius type [ __ ] right there
[ __ ] Monday night fine you up for
the [ __ ] week
there's listening it's tough out there
for a [ __ ]
it's tough out there for a pimp
I [ __ ] sympathize with your
[ __ ] empathize whatever the
[ __ ] the word is they're making it
tougher than what it is take the Doyle
out of your mind don't worry about nut
nobody's coming to get you the Russians
are under control
and [ __ ] it you'll be fine mind your
business look straight ahead you don't
know nothing
seyeong train I easy I did 9:25 he
almost worked
yeah bigger took you two hours to either
me everybody everybody unison Lee's
going to change the sing it please going
through changes it's time for another
Bangla Roshi and let me pass that down
to you uncle Joey now you know what the
[ __ ]
we're not gonna do Bonds Joey why are
you on there it's like Sandra Bullock if
you're not gonna show me your [ __ ] I
don't want to see you no more you know
I'm saying right or wrong it's time for
Sandra Bullock to show that little
monkey enough there's enough
sign the petition right now call 1 888
Sanders show me that Bush and you're
right or wrong is it not time for saying
a book to show that [ __ ] that's it I
don't wanna see no more movies and you
raise some black kids and hanging out
and [ __ ] being a cop I don't need
that [ __ ] I want to see here's a dirty
prostitute with the hip I don't [ __ ] for
League look at him he tells me terrible
as I'm telling you guys he conscious on
periscope this little [ __ ]
[ __ ] I gotta figure out what
he's for substitute stars look at him
he's over there I got your sandwiches my
wife made you a nice roast beef with
Swiss I'm Italian and and some couple
pieces when I got out she had a [ __ ]
platter like this was a hotel I go don't
break she had mustards and tackle him
the sandwich dry there's like Fidel
Castro's we don't [ __ ] around here
well going through change
I'm happy you people here - what world
record we believe in 2006 [ __ ] time
immemorial you don't say who the [ __ ]
are you dealing with rooster buddy what
do you think just ol Joe but dog you
know with a little save a sir we don't
[ __ ] around here at the church at what's
happening now we're like Jesus we touch
[ __ ] fish that turns into lobster you
know saying little [ __ ] you think you're
dealing with here anyway I'm happy you
[ __ ] shut up they're gonna have
a tremendous show there's one of my
favorite [ __ ] characters the reason
why cuz he's real
whenever I see him there's never a
script [ __ ] he just met with Johnny
Depp for lunch he just tells you this
and I just went down and they're a bunch
of [ __ ] months and that's it I come
on again tomorrow here we go here we go
this is Lee at 2:00 in the morning oh
[ __ ] he looks like Jesus on Saturday
have to [ __ ] after good fries what
Trump don't worry about nothing Trump's
with crumbs watching [ __ ] what are you
gonna do Trump's watch and everybody if
you're Mexican Trump's watching if you
[ __ ] whatever you are chumps watching
you [ __ ] so keep it up let's do
another Bonnaroo knee and we'll get this
podcast [ __ ] started alright
all right that's it I like it
it's what I'm talking about
if you're a lady do shotguns with your
man they love we love blowing smoke up
your face yeah [ __ ] we do anything
get titties we don't give a [ __ ]
we're savages [ __ ]
[Music]
they say when you have a [ __ ] up here
to blow pot smoke in it and it [ __ ]
something app I swear to god I realize I
never let nobody blow smoke in my ear
but sometimes you do what you got think
I'm saying what's happening you bad
[ __ ] here let loose Monday
night you know zero [ __ ] as their as
the Gentile said zero [ __ ] nada this is
really zero [ __ ] you understand me you
know I love you [ __ ] savages
youtube.com slash seized last Joey Diaz
my main man Chris Porter Lisa at is
beautiful beautiful savage of death
that's all you need to know
ten minutes youtube.com slash C / listen
I'm stone to the [ __ ] guilt looking up
yourself [ __ ]
what I look like the information booth
at the [ __ ] Airport I love you
[ __ ] if it snows [ __ ] why
because I'm still going to Baltimore I'm
going to look for the black people from
the wire it's over we got to reunite
that [ __ ] cast get some crack get
some hos get some crack goes back out
there it's been a little boring out
there lately that's right anyway I love
you [ __ ] youtube.com slash c /
Joey Diaz leaves over that turning
purple he's going deep mm by himself
this one guys Lee is the last savage
left
nobody would walk at me I'm Tom Owen
Benjamin the star went for a walk and
never came back
it was a Bruce Springsteen he went for a
pack of cigarettes it's over she's still
waiting at the house for child support
I love you [ __ ] I wait ten
minutes I'll be don't go nowhere
get the reef already at the heroin
that's the paint whatever the [ __ ] you
got don't worry about will send you to a
rehab on us on the UM alright Chris
Herren will give you a call at home and
straight you to [ __ ]
I love you bastards from the bottom my
heart you got me foaming at the mouth
this [ __ ]